is you know one percent of the world are  placed in power and 99 of the world are  the audience so that one percent of the  world this idea of the United Nations  this is the world that needs to come  together this is the world that I mean  here's the obvious go-to Biden doesn't  listen to Elon Musk  the president of the United States does  not have meetings with Elon Musk that is  hey here come come come get me that's  I know I'm not supposed to say that  Biden but that's  and obviously because I've been deemed  with mental health all this I have the  right to use whatever words that I like  to use well that's interesting so  somebody ask another question well yeah  let me ask you on that so you just you  just said something very inflammatory  about President Biden it will as you  know offend a lot of people and it will  particularly offend people who work in  mental health you say you should not use  a word like